I know that when you look at tomorrow
and I you think these two love Avatar I
watched the first one yeah you haven't
seen either I have seen both of them oh
the first one definitely in Clips we
have however seen the brand new game
from Ubisoft uh Avatar frontiers of
Pandora in a behind closed doors session
at summer game Fest honestly I don't
know what I expected from this game we
gotta get this out of the way first in
terms of all of the Ubisoft properties
you could possibly compare this game to
and I do not mean to sound reductive
however there was one very particular
animation that I have seen multiple
times
Far Cry yeah it is uh do a far cry but
uh Avatar so I think
to lay some groundwork about what uh
Pandora is
you are not a human being in an avatar
you you are you are a navi you are you
were born on Pandora however as a child
you were kidnapped by the humans and you
were essentially raised as a human so
you have zero connection to the navi
people their way of life uh or even
really Pandora itself you're trained to
be a Sleeper Cell basically yes but the
events of the movie meant that the
humans left leave you and you're the
students behind and because of the
kindness of one of your teachers you're
put into a cryo sleep 15 years later the
events of the second movie when the
humans come back you are awaken and you
decide to side with the people your
people your Navi there's a period where
you live on Pandora and you kind of
experience the freedom that you were
denied when you were kidnapped and then
putting cryostasis so I think that's the
period where they're like they establish
what you fight for yeah and I mean
honestly
is it feeds into the whole purpose of
the you know stranger to strange
landness but also it's not retreading
movie ground yeah too much and a good
way to kind of gamify the world of
Pandora and also give you like a growth
path because it's like you explore
different parts of a Pandora that
haven't been shown in the movie before
and each of them has their own tribes
and and like groups that have their own
cultures and each culture has something
that you don't know about because you've
been kept away from it or and that
translates to an ability whatever it's
like healing or like the ability to tame
animals or fly or hunt or whatever it
may be so as far as like formats for
video games work it's surprisingly solid
and compelling so obviously because you
were raised by humans the the weapons
that you are attuned with and you're
able to use a gun guns yeah and so
there's a very strange Point you'll see
it in the trailer where a navi
assault rifle it's very strange but then
as you get further in the game you
obviously get things like different
kinds of bows uh yeah trap things using
weapons of your people the weapons of
your people and so I mean there's one
point they opened the weapon wheel I
went oh that's that's very fun [__] I
will but the thing you know you
obviously fighting against the humans
you have your flying companion so
there's stuff on the ground you can do
and obviously you can have this air
aerial combat going on the far cryness
comes from the fact that the humans are
putting up you know they're doing the
thing again they are mining they don't
care about the world of Pandora so they
set up minds and outposts and you go
around and you liberate baby
game so that nature can take them back
and when you liberate the outposts you
do genuinely open the fuse box I didn't
do that that was the animation I was
referring to so there's obviously that
element to it you can see the Far Cry
DNA in there I'm already interested and
also a little bit nervous about how big
the game
yeah
a real Trope in Ubisoft is
also you know there's things like
hunting there is Scavenging there's a
meal system in there so you kind of
gather ingredients and you mix meals and
that kind of changes your because it's
skill tree and stuff yeah
it is it feels quite big and that is it
looks beautiful it looks really nice now
other game I would liken it to is
Horizon like it looks very Horizon like
in vibrant saturation and very vibrant
very saturated the colors I think as
well because it is such a Fantastical
World Avatar that it looks alien and it
really nails that yeah and I think as
you're going around and you're seeing
you know the creatures the Flora the
fauna it all looks so unusual and it's
so striking and there's there's Parts
where you're in the first person parkour
and you're on this tree and the the
things attached to the tree sort of
shrinking and growing in all different
colors and when you're flying through
the air on your is it an ikron I think
it's called an ikron which you can name
uh there's a selection of names that you
can pick and they really want you to
form a bond with you it's there
throughout the game once you get it yeah
yeah they want you to form a bond with
this so it looks very very interesting
my hesitation comes from we've been
burned by ubisoft's approach to open
world game design icons
yeah I don't want to see a beautiful
Pandora littered with bloody icons yeah
but also I mean the main thing for me
that struggling to kind of get on board
with is that Avatar as a franchise is
never necessarily hid for me I'm
interested to see who the audience is
going to be that shows up for Frontier
this is the truest test of whether
licensed properties still have the kind
of juice that they had previously where
it was like oh I've watched Avatar and
that was okay oh there's a game I'm
gonna buy that my major concern is
Avatar is a beautiful world that people
love and it's got this whole intricate
lore and and like this systems and that
kind of stuff
I hope that in stuffing that it into an
Ubisoft kind of framework
that isn't lost so I'm interested in
seeing how this game comes out I feel
like it could find an audience at the
moment I look at it and I'm like I don't
know if I'll stick with this I
definitely want to see what they have to
offer and it could be if we're lucky an
evolution of the Far Cry formula that is
the best case scenario and if Avatar is
the vessel they needed to have to make
figure out how to make better first
person open more Shooters I'm all for it
the avatars yeah if it's the Avatar or
baking other game is great
uh we'll have more on Avatar frontiers
of Pandora on Gamespot for all of the
rest of our summer game first coverage
make sure to check out the YouTube
channel and the website we'll see you
next time